I've always envied your voice yeah I've
interviewed you many times whenever we
are on the show I think I you know I'm
cursed with this voice and you have this
fantastic voice and quite long and what
I'm always thinking did did that voice
show up later in life
or I came with this voice know when I
was in elementary school when I was six
I always had a big voice right so in
elementary school I was brought to the
they had an assembly every Friday and
you had to stand as a student body and
they do the Pledge of Allegiance and all
that and I was brought to the front to
lead it oh that's because I had a big
voice then right right so I kind of
developed this sound and this cultivated
this sound over the years it has worked
for you it works very very nice nice
yeah but it's weird if I'm trying to
sort of like not be noticed and I talk
cuz I talk loud sometimes and people
will stop and go oh I heard your voice
and I knew it was you
that's gonna be cool who is that guy one
of the many people that live in here I
was like I was recognizing you you got
you got you knew you wanted to be doing
this at a pretty young age yeah I
discovered acting I came to acting at
the age of 10 professionally I but I did
little things in school
starting with Elementary School where I
did my first performance in like a dance
recital oh and everybody forgot the last
move except for me so everyone else just
stopped everybody else stopped and I did
the last move can I show it to you sure
yeah really simple
can't here and here spin
yeah and so you know from that one
moment my mother was able to deduce that
you know I was either gonna be you know
in showbiz or something else yeah
something bad or a jewelry box
mom Laurence Fishburne
[Applause]
we had a picture of you were in a soap
opera yes probably think we have a
picture of One Life to Live it's
adorable wait and and did you did you
learn because I would think in a way
being on a soap opera would be amazing
training because that's hard work yeah
it was great you have to you have to do
like a great volume in a short period of
time I worked with the great Tommy Lee
Jones who I learned a lot Wow on that
particular show he intimidates me
should I be intimidated by Tommy Lee
Jones at all okay no you just got to
stand up get in his face and stand up
and not be afraid when he says things do
you like who wrote this right what's
your name what's your name my name is
Tony I still think you'd fight as a kid
you were into comic books I love comic
books still love comic books yeah yeah
so much so that I would steal them you
would steal comic books since they've
got expensive you know I started reading
they were ten cents that's the excuse
for old Ealing then they went up to
teach cheap cars used to be
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right so since so okay so you decided it
was your right to - to steal these
comics in order for me to further my can
you know further my education so that I
was reading yeah so I could completely
yeah can you are you allowed to disclose
your method of stealing I would but I
don't want to encourage theft right you
know good thank you I mean immediately
stolen the whole crowd its crew did it
but you know I can't snot likes like you
know yeah but if you steal as I say this
is what a life of crime you might claim
Morpheus become world famous